okay hey everyone Dogan here so today we
are up at Apu it's mecon Asia Pacific
University I used to work up here doing
student Recruitment and in the past on
this channel I made a video actually
talking about Apu how it's possible to
go from an American High School for
example directly to University in Japan
I really wanted to communicate that fact
to as many high school students as
possible that are interested in Japan I
would have wanted to know that when I
was when I was in high school however
when we put that video out of of course
we naturally got a lot of questions from
students that were interested in hearing
not from me but from students that are
currently studying here and from The
Faculty the teachers as well so we're
doing another sponsored video with APU
and we're going to be doing that today
hearing directly from the people that
currently study and work here and before
that I think it'd probably be best if we
kind of review some basic information
about the university so let's do that
now
[Music]
Apu is located in beppu which is in oyta
prefecture in Kyushu the most
Southwestern island of Japan of the four
big Islands there are about 6 000
students at Apu so it's kind of on the
smaller end especially when you compare
it to a much larger American University
or some of the larger universities in
Japan
and the thing that makes it AAP very
interesting in terms of the general
atmosphere is that half of those
students as well as half of the faculty
for that matter are from outside of
Japan so half of the faculty and half of
the students are Japanese and then the
other half is from about a hundred or so
different countries and regions outside
of Japan so despite the university being
located in Japan it doesn't really feel
like a traditional Japanese University
it feels very International you're
constantly hearing different languages
seeing people from all different
backgrounds and it's very unique in that
sense you often find yourself asking am
I am I really in Japan right now it
almost feels like an airport more
sometimes in terms of General feel than
any specific place
I first met with three current Apu
students Salome from Kenya is in her
fifth semester in the College of Asia
Pacific studies or APS
Sparrow from the United States is in his
third semester in the College of
International Management or APM Shirley
from Indonesia is in her fifth semester
also studying in the College of
International Management
okay and now we are joined by three
students that are currently attending
Apu this will kind of be the meat of the
video you guys can hear directly from
the source so to speak the the first
question that I have is how did you end
up in Japan and at Apu specifically so
originally I was actually going to go to
a university in the United States I was
planning to go to University of La
Crosse if you know if that's in
Wisconsin okay but um actually one of my
online friends who was abroad in Britain
at the time mentioned like oh you can go
abroad it's like an option because I was
worried about affordability of college
act right yeah and so yeah in the states
of course the states yes that's
something that always comes to mind you
it's like it's actually a lot cheaper to
go abroad yeah did Big Bell is an actual
thing I could do at the time due to
covid I was online for school so I
started studying Japanese as like a fun
Pastime hobby thing and so from there I
was like oh maybe I'll look at Japanese
colleges you know kind of like joking
like haha I like not go type of thing
but then actually I was watching one of
your videos and from there if you
mentioned I looked it up if you still
had applications open I applied really
loved the college loved the like you
said the aspect of learning Japanese
with an actual other major yeah from
their the rest of the kind of history
and I came here okay what do you plan on
doing after you graduate from Apu and
what are you studying to set yourself up
for that goal actually I'm very
passionate about education so I think
growing up in a very small city in
Indonesia I can see a big educational
gap between like just like the smaller
cities and like the bigger cities right
so I think one of my long-term goal is
to actually come back to Indonesia and
start my own educational project So
currently I am studying business and
International Management I'm
particularly very interested in social
entrepreneurship yeah so I think the
seminars that I'm doing all kind of like
targeted towards the social
entrepreneurship okay yeah in my home
country Kenya there's a lot of issues
particularly relating to women and
women's rights and education of women so
that's kind of more so what I'm
interested in and I also hope to pursue
my postgraduate studies as well in one
of those areas and then hopefully be
able to go up and set go back and set up
like you know an NGO where we can go and
do community outreach for women to
educate them to empower them yes so
that's kind of where my interest lies
great thank you very much
well for me I am kind of younger than
both of you here I'm still a little
second year first semester so I don't
have like the hard outline of where I'm
going to go what I'm going to do at Apu
I've actually gotten really interested
in accounting I was taking accounting
you're like oh this just makes sense I
didn't actually even have to study it
just made sense to me I was like oh if
we're gonna you know credit debit all
that it was just like oh for doing
stocks is it just how it would work I
think and it just does it's very logical
yeah just logical just made sense to me
and so from there I was kind of like
okay I'm definitely going down the
accounting path I love this and so from
there I still am kind of deciding if I
want to do accounting within a Japanese
company or if I want to go back abroad
say Canada or possibly like New Zealand
or European country I'm still very
deciding on that because I am only a
second year I have right bit of time to
kind of get there and within like the
accounting field I'm still kind of
deciding if I want to like try to go
more towards auditing or more towards
like assisting accounting stuff like
that I'm still very much learning my way
kind of through it from there I'd like
to transition to kind of what's a
typical day at Apu like for you kind of
from when you wake up in the morning to
when you take out the trash
in the in the evening I personally live
with the roommate so you know I'll wake
up and I'll be like we have to go you
know so then she's like no why are you
waking me up I'm like we have to go I
checked the bus time and then you know
get ready eat breakfast with her we'll
usually just have our usual morning
conversation and then get on the bus and
on the bus as a wave of other Apu
students also having woken up early and
dressed and everyone's like serious on
their phone like school you know and
then um I'll get to campus I'll head to
class and I'll have my day of classes
sometimes I will have four periods of
classes sometimes I'll have one period
of class and after class maybe I'll hang
out with my friends for some time head
to the library to do some work and then
take the bus back down and then in the
evening usually cook dinner do
assignments or maybe we'll go out we'll
go and eat in some of the nice places
restaurants around Buffalo and then come
back and you know just kind of like
finish up for the evening and then yeah
it's like that's basically my typical
day I don't know what about you guys so
for me I'm also downtown I'm not in AP
house anymore so very similar experience
there but for me I know I can't wake up
so I did not take any first period of
course okay because I I don't know some
people love waking up at like 7 30 I'm
not that guy I can't do that I I need to
sleep you know until like eight maybe
nine and then from there normally it's
wake up if I'm feeling like I don't
normally have a little cereal maybe or
if I'm running I want to have more sleep
time get on the bus come up Lawson or we
also cafeteria up here and capture
that's true love captures here yeah
that's cool stop by grab cafeteria food
and then normally I'll go to class
um this semester I'm not doing Japanese
actually I'm focusing more on my circle
activities actually and so I'll normally
go to my like Supply management class or
whatever very class I have on the day
and normally the afternoons depending on
the day I'll either be working and for
that I normally do English teaching as
well very similar experience so I'll
quickly go back downtown and for me I
travel a lot for English teaching so I
might be going to Fukuoka one day oh
really yes it's very very good I very
much enjoy it and then inside all that
fitting and assignments and circle
activities very busy
yeah I'm actually kind of forced to wake
up in the morning because I have like
four out of five days where I have like
my first period so it's kind of first
period starts at at 8 45 okay but
usually we get to campus early because
my roommate and I always love this so in
the morning the cafeteria has like a
special offer of the 100 yen breakfast
okay so you get like one rice one miso
soup and like three side dishes and
that's what our breakfasts are like kind
of like every morning so we love just
like eating that and then after that
classes classes and then sometimes on
several days I have like internships
after classes so I I will go to the
tourist information center or just
travel around bepu to like kind of like
guiding people guiding tourists and then
yeah after that a lot of meetings either
for like academics like group work and
stuff or just like meetings for like
circles clubs activities and then yeah
and then that's the whole day wow
I think I love the uh the 100 yen
breakfast it seems like a pretty decent
meal it's a very good meal yes
yeah so you can save a lot of money that
way um so speaking of
money finances
um of course pepper is much cheaper to
live than
well most most major cities
anywhere in the world but certainly a
lot cheaper than a place like Tokyo or
Temple University is which is also a
very good school but you can certainly
save a lot more money in a smaller City
like beppu but I was kind of curious
I hope this isn't uh too personal but
Apu offers many different kinds of
scholarships and I was curious about if
any of you guys had received any
scholarships of any kind
if that's okay to talk about yeah I
think we're okay with that I think that
yeah okay so for me personally I got the
65 reduction scholarship which is
offered by a few there's multiple
different tiers that's just the one I
got and so already for me I was already
worried about Finance that's why I was
going abroad and then that on top that
really does help us this tier yes
because it's actually enough that I can
completely support myself on my own I
don't need help from my parents I don't
need loans I don't need anything like
that of the sorts it's very livable
which is really amazing to me for
approximately one year the tuition at
Apu if we're using the conversion rate
from dollars to Yen today October
November excuse me 2022 it's about ten
thousand dollars for the entire year now
you're getting 65 percent reduction on
on that so you're paying I'm like around
3K ish around there yeah and that's
insane to me yes like cheaper than my
local Community College in the US that
gets yes very much an insane concept to
me that I can fully support myself on my
own without loans or my parents or
anyone to absolutely and of course on
top of that as as we just mentioned
earlier Beth boo is a very cheap city to
live do you mind if I ask how much
you're paying for rent for rent because
I do also do room share uh but it is a
bit bigger because we want to do a 3 LDK
to have a bit more room with that and um
for I don't know if you guys know three
LDK if that's basically we have three
rooms the living room and a kitchen
connected okay and so for that I pay
including electricity water and
everything roughly Yeoman which is
around like 350 yeah maybe about 300 300
yeah around these three months yeah
which again is very very insane to me
for livability and everything yes
absolutely and do you guys uh pay a
comparable amount for your rent each
month mine's pretty similar okay yeah
and then we split it down the middle so
that's even cheaper okay yeah yeah with
your roommate
and are either of you receiving
scholarships as well or yeah I'm
actually very lucky to receive a hundred
percent of the tuition reduction
scholarship so yeah that's no tuition
fee and I guess on top of that I also
received some kind of like additional
scholarships so the tuition reduction
only covers the tuition fee but then for
the living costs there are multiple
scholarships that you can apply once you
enroll in the University especially if
you're from second year onwards so I
applied to some very lucky to receive
some as well so it kind of covers my
living costs as well so kind of like
saving money during University life so
that combined with the 100 yen breakfast
yes
yes wow that's great yeah
um yeah yeah
um so mine's actually pretty similar to
Shirley's I can say so I was also really
lucky to receive the 100 scholarship
okay and on top of that Apu also has
student support scholarships
specifically called jasso right also is
of course an organization on its own in
Japan and Apu partners with them to
support students maybe for academic
Excellence or just generally to support
students who they feel maybe they want
to continue having the same momentum
they have in classes and extracurricular
so I also am able to receive that as
well and that really helps me because
I'm able to pay my rent the transport
becomes cheaper you know just every
small minuscule cost that you face day
to day
all right
um
[Music]
thank you
so so yeah I came to like before I came
to Apu it was like zero and then AP was
kind of like the first time I have ever
learned or even be familiar with
Japanese as a language so yeah and then
after that a lot of experience just like
maybe from outside of classes activities
like you get to meet people living in AP
house with like Japanese students or
like doing activities like teaching
assistant or like resident assistant
where you can meet your Japanese
co-workers so I think that really helps
a lot in like improving Japanese
language so
foreign
[Laughter]
foreign
[Laughter]
thank you all very much for your time I
can see a bright future for all of you
already so I can't wait to see what each
of you do in the future and again thank
you thank you thank you so much for
having us
next I spoke with Professor Akiko Honda
the director of apu's Center for
language education Professor Honda has
been teaching Japanese at Apu since the
university opened in April of 2000.
hi
hi
hello
this is
so
foreign
[Music]
I know
um
huh I'm always on YouTube
foreign
[Music]
foreign problems
[Music]
[Music]
I think
finally I sat down with Professor Sarah
camardomov the dean of academic Affairs
originally from Kazakhstan he joined Apu
in 2009 after studying and teaching at
the Nagasaki medical school as the dean
of academic Affairs he oversees apu's
academic programs you can come to study
at Apu at an undergraduate level even if
you've never studied Japanese before
which I think is of course fantastic
because many people my past
self-included would have loved to go to
a university
immediately after graduating from high
school but I just assumed that if it was
a Japanese University I would have had
to know at least some Japanese but of
course at Apu you can know no Japanese
and come directly here right Logan you
correctly mentioned that Japanese
language is a big barrier for
international students to come to Japan
but Apu as a few other universities of
Japan they provide opportunity to study
a bachelor degree and graduate degree
without knowing Japanese language
and for bachelor degree students they
could study Japanese while they entered
at The Bu it's very difficult to even
compare Apu to well not only other
universities in Japan but even if you're
just interested in studying Japanese
it's such a unique environment for that
particular thing as well yes exactly
studying Japanese
it will be connected to the final goal
so many students come to Japan maybe
firstly they come because they're
interested in Japan but gradually they
start to think about what they should do
after the graduation the percentage of
students who get job after graduating at
epu quite high it's at average more than
95 percent of students who graduate from
Apu they find a job and many of them
they find job here in Japan that's why
learning language in Japanese language
at the same time they know their own
native language and maybe a couple of
other languages so it become a huge
opportunity to them to be hired by
Japanese companies who are looking for
finding connection
with countries outside of Japan one of
the great experiences that I always had
here was going to the gym and it was
just so interesting because there were
students from all over the country and
they were all friends not because they
were trying to learn English from each
other or learn Japanese from each other
but because they all had this same kind
of hobby you there's much more to learn
from that kind of relationship ship I
believe as well in terms of the language
element as well right yeah exactly and I
think learning language is one part of
living in Japan and that's the one to
understand the culture Apu is quite
take this spot very seriously yeah and
for all newcomers first year students
Apu provide opportunity to live in a few
house and if you house I think it's a
first step for them to understand and
learn like
life culture at Japan if you is going to
build a new a view house it's a very
interesting concept because we have a
new college to be established here debut
from next year and in line with this one
a new Apu house with a number of beds I
think about 260. okay and it is four
floor building and the entrance to that
building would be from the fourth floor
and design is quite interesting it's a
very good nice view to see into the
nature
and a lot of rooms where students could
communicate and as you mentioned
communication between students is very
important and why ipu is going to
establish a new College yes because the
current situation in the world is not so
stable so sustainability is becoming one
of the key Awards of making and keeping
this world in a more safe manner a more
peaceful Manner and in new College a
word incorporate the concept of keeping
the world most sustainable be more
friendly to environment and at the same
time we would like to increase tourism
opportunity like International
tourism and the tourism is another way
to sustain local communities like to
share their culture right and invite
more people from abroad
absolutely now Japanese companies
they're looking for a very smart and
creative individuals so I think the camp
samples which we have at Apu provides
opportunity for students to explore more
about their own individuality at the
same time to understand different
cultures because we live in a world
which become more open to us as
societies and countries and this is a
place where you could practice how you
could survive in This World Without
Borders yes absolutely and I think that
this is actually a really good example
I'm an American YouTuber living in Japan
Sensei is from Kazakhstan teaching in
Japan and we're
we're talking about a Japanese
University yes and of course this is
indicative of what's happening in Japan
at large exactly it's a very good
example right maybe we didn't imagine
this situation several years ago right
yeah and I think that for anyone among
of your viewers so if you are interested
in Japan your dream maybe is not so
difficult not so difficult to achieve
all right well I want to say thank you
again to seriku Sensei the academic the
dean of academic Affairs at Apu thank
you so much for your time and um
is there anything else that you would
like to say to any incoming students
right yes thank you too for a wonderful
interview and I would like to say to
your viewers if you would like to know
more about Apu we have a weekly Workshop
which you could attend online and you
would know much more information about
Apu in English okay great thank you very
much for your time thank you too okay so
that's the video I hope that by hearing
from the students that actually study
here as well as the faculty that teach
here you've been able to get a better
idea of what Apu is actually like I'll
be doing a webinar with APU in the near
future you can find some details down
below but I want to say thank you to Apu
again for sponsoring this video and I'll
see you guys again soon
foreign
[Music]